breaking right now Metro Police  confirming a second homicide on the same  street over the weekend both happen in  the Central Valley near MLK and Lake  Mead Boulevard officers have arrested  this man 38-year-old Jason Spellman for  allegedly shooting and killing a man  yesterday police tell 8 news now  Spellman and the victim 43-year-old  Clarence Harvey III were at a nearby  gathering before that shooting Harvey  then left walking in the area when  Spelman police say drove up and fired  several shots Harvey later died at the  hospital Spellman was found later that  evening and arrested now facing open  murder charges